al final lo más extraño sucedió
el pasado 9 de marzo del 2022 tuvieron
lugar las últimas elecciones
presidenciales de Corea del Sur unas
elecciones que amenazaban con romper
toda una tradición histórica en la joven
democracia surcoreana la alternancia de
gobierno entre conservadores y
progresistas cada 10 años pero esta vez
queridos amigos amigas las cosas fueron
diferentes os hemos hablado ya de ello
en las claves de la semana el boletín
que recibís todos los que formáis parte
de la comunidad de visualpolitik en
patreon Corea del Sur acaba de
experimentar todo un volantazo político
cinco años después los conservadores
regresan al poder y no lo hacen con un
candidato cualquiera
visteis Este vídeo
[Música]
ha sido la respuesta a la victoria de
jung shock atentos pero un momento antes
de continuar la Guerra de Ucrania ha
hecho que los bancos centrales de todo
el mundo también den un volantazo
monetario tras más de una década de
políticas monetarias Ultra expansivas y
enormes programas de gasto público la
inflación de los países desarrollados ha
escalado hasta su mayor nivel de los
últimos 40 años esto ha hecho que ahora
los bancos centrales comiencen a tomar
cartas en el asunto La pregunta es hasta
dónde escalarán los tipos de interés
para responder a esta pregunta No te
pierdas el último vídeo de si lo hubiera
sabido el canal de información
financiera de mutuactivos con el que
colaboramos os dejamos el enlace abajo
en la descripción dicho esto arranquemos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
si hace apenas 12 meses le hubieran
dicho a june que un año más tarde se
convertiría en presidente Seguro seguro
que se habría echado a reír el
presidente electo surcoreano es todo un
outsider de la política hasta marzo del
2021 fue el fiscal general del país
nombrado por cierto por el propio
presidente saliente mucheín todo un plot
twist
[Música]
como fiscal general joongs of Joy fue
conocido por ser implacable contra la
corrupción de hecho fue el artífice del
encarcelamiento de dos expresidentes
surcoreanos Lee mingback y parkoune que
fueron acusados de prácticas corruptas
como sobornos y tráfico de influencia
sin embargo tal y como veremos eso no
fue lo que le hizo ganar las elecciones
una victoria Por cierto lograda por un
extremo margen el 48,56
de los votos frente al
47,83% de su contrincante progresista
menos de un punto de diferencia menos de
250.000 votos
ahora bien Qué explica que se haya roto
la histórica alternancia de gobierno
cada 10 años por qué munchain se ha
convertido en el primer presidente cuyo
partido ha perdido la confianza de los
surcoreanos tras el primer mandato Qué
futuro se avecina en la Península de
Corea Pues bien veámoslo
la herencia de Moon
[Música]
munchain se presentó a las elecciones
del 2017 con una serie de promesas
quizás demasiado grande lo cuentes y
arriesgadas para un mandato de 5 años
recordad que en Corea del Sur no existe
la reelección presidencial
[Música]
unchain prometió llevar a cabo una
completa renovación social económica y
política y por ejemplo incluía terminar
de una vez por todas con las estrechas
conexiones entre la política y los
chebble los grandes conglomerados
empresariales de Corea del Sur también
prometió trasladar la oficina del
presidente fuera de seúl terminar con la
energía nuclear civil y las dos cosas
más importantes solucionar el grave
problema de los precios de la vivienda
que hay en seúl y su área metropolitana
y conseguir de una vez por todas la paz
con Corea del Norte
[Música]
Pues bien cinco años después ninguno de
estos grandes objetivos se había
cumplido totalmente incluso podríamos
decir que teniendo en cuenta sus propias
expectativas su gobierno ha sido un
fracaso ni siquiera logró cumplir una
promesa menor como es trasladar la
oficina del presidente fuera de seúl
algo que por cierto su propio partido le
echan cara al nuevo presidente cosas de
la política
junimun chocan por el traslado de la
oficina presidencial los legisladores
del partido democrático cuestionaron en
la reunión la prisa y algunos insinuaron
que yoon podría tener razones no
reveladas para no querer mudarse a la
casa azul como por ejemplo el feng shui
claro que esta es la cuestión más
anecdótica en el caso de la política
energética por ejemplo mucho más
trascendente en 2017 nada más llegar al
poder munchain anunció un plan para
eliminar progresivamente la energía
nuclear del país terminaremos con el
plan de generación de energía nuclear y
allanaremos el camino para una era libre
de energía nuclear cancelaremos los
planes existentes para construir nuevas
plantas y no extenderemos la vida útil
de las centrales nucleares
qué mal envejecen algunas hemerotecas
porque claro con los altísimos precios
del gas natural y el petróleo y con el
carbón también por las nubes las cosas
cambiaron radicalmente el propio
gobierno de munt de repente pareció
abanderar la campaña pronuclear el
ministro de comercio y energía de Corea
del Sur visitó la central nuclear de
hanul en la región de kangoon y pidió
que se completen rápidamente los
reactores nucleares en construcción
sugiriendo una relajación en la política
de eliminación gradual de la energía
nuclear frente al aumento vertiginoso de
los precios del combustible que sí desde
luego rectificar es de sabios pero no sé
en solo cinco años y después de haber
sido tan categóricos no sé que
reconozcan por lo menos Entonces que
estaban equivocados no Pero esperad
porque no hemos hecho nada más que
empezar por ejemplo Es cierto que su
política se acuerda del Norte ha
supuesto el mayor periodo de estabilidad
militar en la Península de Corea desde
la Sunshine poli de finales de los años
90 Pero al final salvo por sus tres
Cumbres con kim jong-un y las dos de
Trump en las que actúa como mediador los
resultados no han ido mucho más allá
habéis visto el vídeo No pues eso
durante la presidencia de muchaín Corea
del Norte continuó su campaña de
provocaciones constantes por ejemplo
opionyan lanzó decenas de misiles de
diversos Rango continuó insultando a las
autoridades del Sur en sus medios
estatales e incluso pocos meses Después
de llegar muna al poder probaron una
bomba atómica de hidrógeno Eso sí esto
último las pruebas nucleares sí que se
Han detenido en Seco la Península de
Corea lleva cuatro años y medio sin ver
una sola detonación nuclear claro que
también puede ser que simplemente esa
fase del programa atómico Norteño ya
fuera completada la guinda del pastel se
vivió en junio de 2020 cuando Corea del
Norte hizo saltar por los aires ojo de
forma literal la oficina de las
intercoreana de Quiénes son un símbolo
del diálogo entre las dos coreas desde
entonces los progresos diplomáticos
entre ambas coreas se congelaron
por supuesto a pesar de sus promesas
Moon no logró cerrar un acuerdo de paz
que formalmente ponga fin de una vez por
todas a la guerra de Corea
[Música]
porque sí para los que no lo sepáis la
guerra de Corea no terminó oficialmente
en 1953 ese año se firmó un simple
armisticio un alto el fuego Así que
técnicamente los dos países continúan en
guerra Pues bien El caso es que a pesar
de sus promesas Moon tampoco consiguió
ese tanto diplomático y sabéis que casi
que mejor mejor no imaginar las
concesiones que hubiera tenido que hacer
para conseguir ese papel por último para
concluir esta lista de grandes fracasos
políticos o promesas no cumplidas
tenemos quizás la cuestión que más ha
Pesado en la derrota del candidato
oficialista la política de vivienda un
tema sobre el que ya os hemos hablado
aquí en visualpolitik desde Entonces
hasta las elecciones pasaron unos dos
años y las cosas no solo no mejoraron
sino que no hicieron más que empeorar
fijaos
[Música]
el precio medio de la vivienda en seúl
que es el área más tensionada se ha
incrementado en un 35% desde que munchen
llegó al poder y alrededor de un 50%
desde el 2015 y en algunas zonas de la
ciudad sean más que duplicado para que
os hagáis una idea esto supone que un
surcoreano que se quiera comprar hoy un
apartamento normal de unos 82 metros
cuadrados en seúl tendría que apoquinar
de media más del 970 mil dólares Cuando
solo tres años antes en 2017 ese mismo
apartamento que hubiera costado unos
590.000 Así que claro noticias como esta
no resultan nada sorprendentes hubo un
admite el fracaso de su política de
vivienda Bueno al menos en este caso sí
lo han admitido algo es algo como os
podéis imaginar esto ha decepcionado
muchísimo a la gente joven que confió
fervientemente en Moon en 2017 quizás
nos acordéis pero se le describía casi
como él Obama surcoreano desde luego
aquí en visualpolitik no nos ha
sorprendido nada de lo ocurrido la mayor
parte de las medidas que tomó mun
estaban dirigidas al limitar la demanda
y muy pocas a incrementar la oferta de
viviendas Pues bien estos han sido En
definitiva los grandes errores que han
terminado provocando un cambio de rumbo
histórico en Corea del Sur un cambio de
rumbo eso sí que ha llegado por los
pelos Y la verdad con poco entusiasmo
por parte de los surcoreanos como se ha
dicho pero ahora la cuestión que podemos
que tenemos que plantearnos es Qué
planes tiene y unsock Joel para Corea
del Sur Pues bien veámoslo
la era june qué le espera a Corea
la victoria por la mínima de jun shock
Joel amenaza con convertirse en todo un
torbellino para la política surcoreana
para la política interna pero también
para el exterior y es que si hay algo
que caracteriza hay un es precisamente
que se trata de un personaje muy
peculiar pero vamos peculiar de narices
of Gold se declara abiertamente
antifeminista y en la campaña le gustaba
jactarse de ello también pertenece a la
congregación cristiana protestante de la
yoido fulgo spell Church Hablamos de una
congregación religiosa de unos 800.000
miembros que es una de las más
conservadoras de Corea y cuyos líderes
encabezan los movimientos anti lgtb en
el país por otro lado el ex fiscal
general es en lo económico seguidor de
las teorías de misas y Freeman en cuanto
a la defensa de Libre Mercado es un
firme partidario de la de regulación y
los impuestos bajos y de hecho se espera
que ponga el mando de la economía del
país a un perfil técnico que sea próximo
a Estas ideas
[Música]
pero concretemos un poco más todo esto
qué os hemos contado Cuáles han sido los
principales factores que han contribuido
a la derrota del oficialismo tras la
presidencia de Moon Así que ahora la
pregunta es Cuáles son exactamente las
propuestas del nuevo presidente para
afrontar todos estos retos Pues bien una
de las políticas que más ha defendido
durante la campaña fue la de apostar de
nuevo por la energía nuclear Sí el
gobierno de mun canceló la construcción
de varios reactores ahora el nuevo
presidente considera que la energía de
los átomos es la mejor forma de hacer
que Corea del Sur consiga durante
décadas energía abundante limpia y
barata de hecho cuando nombró su panel
de expertos del comité para la
transición presidencial se pudieron ver
varios nombres de expertos en energía
nuclear toda una declaración de
intenciones
[Música]
respecto a la vivienda otra de las
grandes preocupaciones sociales del país
Juke se ha comprometido a impulsar la
colaboración publicó privada para
construir dos millones y medio de
viviendas a lo largo y ancho de toda
Corea durante sus cinco años de mandato
de todas ellas una coma tres millones
estarán en seúl eso por el lado de la
oferta por el lado fiscal june dice que
hará justo lo contrario de lo que ha
hecho Moon aliviará las restricciones a
las hipotecas y reducir el impuesto
sobre las ganancias de capital también
ha propuesto revisar el impuesto de
bienes inmuebles para los propietarios
múltiples para así reducir el precio de
los alquileres
Este es un tema que en Corea últimamente
acapara toda la atención pensar que
según la confederación coreana de
sindicatos un surcoreano medio de unos
20 años tardaría de media un siglo en
terminar de pagar por sí solo un
apartamento normal En seúl todo un siglo
de hecho según una encuesta del Herald
business y el instituto de opinión de la
sociedad coreana 1 de cada cuatro
votantes cree que la estabilidad del
mercado inmobiliario es el mayor reto
del nuevo presidente
[Música]
pero es que aquí no termina todo coria
es un país con una política exterior
complicada el gobierno coreano tiene que
lidiar con su vecino comunista del Norte
y hacer un delicado de equilibrio en las
relaciones con china Japón y los Estados
Unidos un equilibrio que no pocas veces
se convierte en todo un quebradero de
cabeza Pues bien todo apunta a que el
próximo gobierno dará un bandazo en su
política exterior para volverse más por
Estados Unidos y también pero Japón lo
que evidentemente puede enfriar algo las
cosas con china sin ir más lejos el
nuevo presidente defiende cosas como
aumentar las baterías antimisiles zaz
estadounidenses un despliegue que ya le
costó a Corea sufrir todo un boicot
comercial y turístico por parte de China
reconstruiré la alianza Corea Estados
Unidos y fortaleceré la alianza
estratégica integral al tiempo que
compartimos los valores fundamentales de
la Democracia liberal una economía de
Mercado y los Derechos Humanos
desarrollaré relaciones bilaterales de
respeto mutu y crearé una relación Corea
Japón orientaba al futuro yuxon Pero
vale a estas alturas del vídeo ya sé lo
que muchos estaréis pensando Y qué
demonios pasa con Corea del Norte pues
os recuerdo la reacción de pyongyang
como todos los presidentes conservadores
y un es partidario de volver a la línea
dura con Peón yang en este caso incluso
es partidario de intentar que Estados
Unidos despliegue más armas estratégicas
en Corea aunque también ha dejado Claro
que está dispuesto a continuar con los
diálogos de paz la verdad es que haga lo
que haga lo más probable es que veamos
constantes tiras y aflojas entre las dos
coreas que por otra parte es lo que ya
viene siendo habitual desde hace décadas
o quizás no quién sabe en Corea el grado
de imprevisibilidad es siempre bastante
alto por último si os parece echemos un
vistazo a las medidas económicas que el
nuevo presidente ha prometido las
medidas con las que espera que Corea del
Sur recupere la vitalidad económica que
tenía antaño atentos
y un anunciado una lucha sin cuartel
contra la inflación reducir la
burocracia y la economía con hasta 80
regulaciones menos para las empresas y
flexibilizar el mercado laboral por
ejemplo para que los trabajadores puedan
trabajar más horas extras algo que
limitó el gobierno Demon también ha
prometido colaborar con Samsung para
estrechar la brecha que actualmente esta
empresa tiene respecto a la taiwanesa
tsmc el mayor fabricante mundial de
semiconductores Esto es algo que el
nuevo presidente considera estratégico
tanto desde el punto de vista económico
como desde el punto de vista de la
seguridad nacional
ya os lo hemos contado tanto en pasados
vídeos como en boletines de patreon los
semiconductores son algo así como el
santo grial para las economías de Taiwán
y de Corea y en general para las
tecnologías avanzadas del Siglo 21
y ya a partir de este punto en las
cuestiones restantes los planes de june
son de momento poco claros Así que en
visualpolitik estaremos particularmente
atentos a Cómo se desarrolla este
aparente volantazo político con el que
Corea del Sur ha pasado de tener un
presidente al que comparaban con Obama a
otro al que comparan con Ronald Reagan
solo el tiempo nos podrá decir si
realmente esto es o no una exageración
de momento te pasamos el turno a ti sí a
ti con lo que has visto crees que el
nuevo presidente podrá corregir los
principales problemas de Corea vivirá
Corea del Sur una especie de Renacer
económico tal y como vaticina june que
sucederá con las relaciones con China y
Corea del Norte déjanos por aquí abajo
tu comentario y si te ha gustado este
vídeo No olvides darle al botón de like
y suscribirte a visualpolitik Para no
perderte ninguna de las novedades que
están por llegar una vez más gracias por
estar ahí un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]